Guten Abend.
Ich bin auch diese Station als Özterein.
Ich möchte gerne mit Ihnen ein Anamnesen-Gespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, gerne Frau Doktor.
Bevor wir über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden sprechen, möchte ich Ihre persönlichen Daten erfahren.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Daniel Reumann.
Daniel mit I und E.
Können Sie bitte Ihre Nachname bestabieren?
H, E, U, M, A, N.
Herr Reumann.
Herr Reumann, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin jetzt 80 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau gebogen?
1. Mai 1942.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich habe mich jetzt länger nicht gebogen.
Ich denke mal ungefähr 65 Kilogramm.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich war einmal 1,75 m.
Herr Reumann, was für die Beschwerden haben Sie?
Wie kann ich für Sie helfen?
Frau Doktor, ich fühle mich sehr schwach,
weil ich seit ungefähr 3 Tagen starken Durchfall habe.
Das ist das Hauptproblem, warum ich zu Ihnen komme.
Ich glaube, ich habe auch viel Physik verloren
und fühle mich auch sehr schwach momentan.
Okay.
Sind die Schmerzen?
Ich habe sie nicht mehr geblieben.
Seit 3 Tagen haben Sie Durchfall.
Haben Sie ungewöhnliches gegessen?
Also, ich weiß nicht genau,
da war mal letzte Woche, ich hatte schon Kartoffelsalat bekommen.
Aufs Essen hier im Pflegeheim.
Ich bin im Durchfall, ich bin im Pflegeheim.
Das ist nicht besonders gut.
Vielleicht war das der Grund, ich weiß aber nicht genau.
Ich habe sie nicht bemerkt, ob Sie ungewöhnliches gegessen haben.
Also, das Einzige, was mir anfällt, ist dieser Kartoffelsalat vor einer Wurfe,
aber ob es daran liegt, weiß ich nicht genau.
Okay.
Haben Ihre Freundin im Pflegeheim ähnliche Beschwerden gehabt?
Ich habe nichts gehört.
Haben Sie Bauchschmerzen?
Also, bevor ich jetzt Durchfall bekomme, habe ich so Bauchkrämpfe.
Aber sie sind nicht so stark, auch nicht immer.
Wenn Sie auf die Toilette gehen, fühlen Sie sich besser?
Dann ist mal kurz ein bisschen der Schmerz besser, aber nicht viel,
kann man nicht so sagen.
Okay.
Hatten Sie früher schon einmal Englisch beschwerden?
Durchfall hatte ich schon ein paar Mal, aber...
Wann hatten Sie?
Also, ich habe immer wieder mal Durchfall jedes Jahr,
eines zweimal, aber das ist nie so schlimm wie jetzt.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Eigentlich nicht, nein.
Müssen Sie sich übergeben?
Nein.
Okay.
Herr Häumann, leiden Sie unter nachschweiß oder kalten schweiß?
Nein, keine Probleme.
Oder haben Sie Fieber oder Stilfrost?
Auch nicht nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab- oder zugenommen?
Ich habe mich nicht gewogen, ich weiß es nicht.
Und haben Sie, wenn man das in der letzten Zeit in der Kleidung klein geworden
oder groß geworden ist?
Das habe ich nicht gemerkt, nein.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Seit drei Tagen ist es nicht gut, aber davor war normal.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihre Stuhl ungewöhnliches habe?
Oder wie sah Ihre Stuhl aus?
Also, es war wässrig, schleimig.
Es war auch einmal gut dabei, aber nur einmal.
Wann haben Sie gesehen?
Gestern.
Haben Sie Probleme bei Wasserlasten?
Jetzt aktuell nicht.
Ich hatte aber mal Probleme gehabt.
Ich war vor ungefähr vier Wochen im Krankenhaus.
Da hatte ich Probleme beim Wasserlasten.
Und da hatte ich auch eine schwere Infektion, gab ich Fieber.
Da habe ich eine Woche lang Antibiotika bekommen,
die ich mit dem Krankenhaus gegen eine Handwerksinfektion habe.
Bekannst du, wer diese Medikamente nehmen?
Ich habe sie damals.
Nein, beim Handwerksinfektion.
Was weiß ich nicht, das habe ich als Infusion bekommen.
Was waren Sie früher auf andere Gründe beim Krankenhaus?
Ja, verschiedene Male wegen Herzproblemen.
Auch wegen Rheuma, weil ich man kann, aber schon viele Jahre her.
Das ist jetzt schon sechs Jahre her.
Ja, ich werde diese Erkrankungen später fragen.
Aber erst mal möchte ich zurückgehebe.
Gibt es bestimmte Auslöser für diesen Durchfall?
Ich habe plötzlich aufgetreten.
Ich habe auch schon lange gedacht, dass es am ersten Weg könnte.
Aber ich weiß es nicht genau.
Vor drei Tagen ging es mir sehr gut.
Haben Sie dagegen etwas eingenommen?
Nein, nicht wirklich.
Haben Sie völlig gefühlt?
Herr Hohmann, haben Sie die Gewerkschaften durchslafen?
Durchslafen, so nicht sagen, dass ich nicht schlafen kann.
Wie ist Ihnen das schwindelig?
Seitdem ich Durchfall habe, habe ich das Grün.
Ich bin wackelig auf dem Bein.
Entschuldigung, ich konnte nicht gut hören.
Als ich durchfall habe, bin ich schwulisch und schwach.
Ich bin auch wackelig auf den Beinen.
Wie oft müssen Sie sich auf die Toilette gehen?
Sechs, sieben Mal.
Gestern war es noch mehr als zehn Mal.
Nach dem Nachts.
Trinken Sie Wasser ausreichend?
Ich glaube nicht, ich habe nicht so viel trinken können.
Herr Hohmann, Sie haben erwähnt, dass Sie Herz- und Räume Probleme haben.
Ich möchte bitte mehr erzählen,
welche chronische Erkrankungen Sie haben.
Ich habe die Erkrankungen von Räume festgestellt.
Vor 20 Jahren hat ich die Gelenken spät,
die Händen, die Helmbogen, die Schultern und die Knien.
Das ist untersucht worden.
Dann hat man Diagnose.
Räume hat die Erkrankungen von Doida, die ich heute noch habe.
Ich habe das MTX, weil du dir gesagt hast, dass ich eine Erkrankung habe.
Ja, stimmt.
Wie viel Milligramm?
15 Milligramm.
Wie oft nehmen Sie?
Einmal pro Jahr.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Erkrankungen?
Dann war ich einmal, kann man auch so 5-6 Jahren wegen Herzproblemen festgestellt werden,
dass ich Herz-Rhythmus-Lärm habe, also Vorruf nehmen kann.
Und dann hat man Medikamente mitgegeben.
Wer ist die Medikamente?
Ich habe das Herz, das Polyponell,
und das Elikris.
Ich habe nicht gefühlt, noch entschuldigt.
Es ist Polyponell.
Und Elikris.
Dann habe ich noch Abibil.
Wie viele Gramm, oder wer ist der, der durch das,
nehmen Sie diese Medikamente?
Amipri, das sind 15 Milligramm morgens.
5 Milligramm.
Richtig.
Und das Polyponell sind auch 2,5 Milligramm morgens und abends.
Ich gebe noch andere Medikamente ein.
Also einmal habe ich dieses MPX, einmal pro Woche.
Ja, ich habe nicht viel.
Dann komme ich jetzt längerem auch dieses Pantopazol,
20 Milligramm, das ist mir damals die Krankenhaus bestätigt worden.
Ich bin jetzt weiter bis 1 Monate mehr.
Jetzt die Milligramm.
Dann habe ich noch wegen meiner großer Vergrößerung
eine Kappe, die als Duo Dart.
Das ist jetzt nicht an der Abends.
Wie viele Milligramm nehmen Sie Duo Dart?
Dann habe ich nicht im Kopf, muss ich nachher dabei gehen.
Und dann habe ich noch, weil ich eine chronische Medikamente
habe, die ich dann noch in der Hand habe,
die ich dann noch in der Hand habe,
die ich noch, weil ich eine chronische,
ob Jungenerkrankung habe, auch ist Viani.
Und in der Laktionsmedikamente,
Viani Discos, dann nämlich morgens im Rahmen zu reingeprügen.
Viani.
Viani, ja.
Welche Probleme beim Jungeln?
COPD, hat der Dr. Gesangstor.
Ja, das kann ich tun.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch Medikamente oder Erkrankungen?
Oder alles was?
Nee, das war es, glaube ich.
Sind Sie früher schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, als junger Mann hatte ich mal eine Blinddammenzündung.
Und dann hatte ich auch mal Gallenblasensteine,
da ist Gallenblase entfernt,
von über 40 Jahren.
Ihre Gallenblase ist entfernt worden?
Richtig, ja.
Ich habe gehört, die Akustik ist nicht gut.
Sie ist schon von der jegelium.
Wir haben sie am letzten Jahr schon.
Schön.
Okay.
Das waren die Medikamente voll auf den anderen, nämlich die Gallenblasensteine.
Ja, wann sehen Sie Gallenblasen-Erzönung operiert worden?
Ungefähr vor 40 Jahren, ich weiß nicht genau.
Sind bei Ihnen irgendwelche Allergien bekannt?
Nein, keine Allergien.
Sind Sie voruständig gewesen?
Den Corona meinen Sie?
Ja.
Ich habe mich dreimal gegeben.
Okay, super.
Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland gewesen?
Nein, ich war schon lange nicht mehr im Ausland.
Okay.
Herr Hoiman, rufen Sie?
Ich habe mal geraucht, aber ich habe vor ungefähr 15 Jahren aufgehört.
Seit 15 Jahren haben Sie nicht geraucht.
Aber früher, wie viel Zigarette haben Sie geraucht?
Ein welchen Zigarettenbrotaten.
Im Weserseitsraum haben Sie viele Jahre geraucht.
Ich habe überlegt, als junger Mann angefangen,
dann bis ungefähr 40 Jahre.
Zwingen Sie Alkohol?
Nein.
Nehmen Sie sonstige Drogen?
Nein, generell Drogen.
Herr Hoiman, was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich war Sachbearbeiter in einer großen Lobistikfirma.
Einigstens Büro-Tätigkeit habe ich ausgeliefert.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verwitzt, wenn ich rausgekommen bin.
10 Jahre.
Ich habe Sie Kinder?
Nein, ich habe keine Kinder.
Ich möchte über Beruf fragen.
Arbeiten Sie noch?
Nein, ich bin jetzt, ich bin rentet.
Ich habe damals, als ich vorhin angefangen habe,
dann auf eine Erfung, die ich als Ende gekommen war,
vertreibte.
Ich habe nicht verstanden, können Sie bitte noch einmal erklären?
Ja, ich bin Rentner.
Damals, als die Rheumarkrankheit aufgetreten ist,
um Frührente bekommen, Erwerbsunfähigkeitsrente.
Da war ich nicht vertreibt.
Wie lange haben Sie Frührente bekommen?
Seit 360 Jahren.
63 Jahre?
Wohnen Sie alleine?
Ich wohne, wie gesagt, im Pflegeheim.
Ich kann mich nicht mehr kümmern.
Ich habe niemanden.
Wie lange haben Sie in Ihrem eigenen Raum?
Oder mit anderen Wohnen zusammengegeben?
Mit anderen, ich habe mein eigenes Zimmer,
aber natürlich Gemeinschaftsräumen.
Ich möchte über Ihre Familie Geschichte fragen.
Wie lange haben Sie in Ihrem Leben noch?
Nein, die sind dann tot.
Ja, waren Sie wütend gestorben?
Mein Vater ist an Lungenkrebs gestorben.
Und meine Mutter hat auch verschiedene Krankheiten
und ist aber ein Schlaganfall gestorben.
Ich habe viele Jahre.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe Geschwister, aber ich habe keine Kontaktkunst.
Eine Schwester haben Sie?
Ich habe eine Schwester und ein Bruder.
Herr Holmann, meinerseits habe ich wichtige Frage gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas Müße fügen?
Was meinen Sie vor, da muss ich im Krankenhaus bleiben?
Oder kann ich wieder ins Heim zurück?
Wie lange muss ich im Krankenhaus bleiben?
Wir müssen bei uns bleiben,
weil ich Ihre ausführliche Untersuchung und Behandlung machen muss.
Ich will Ihre Beschwerden bezüglich vorheriger Antibiotika einnehmen.
Muss ich noch mal Antibiotika einnehmen?
Ich habe mich gehört.
Nein, Sie müssen andere Antibiotika einnehmen.
Aber erst mal werde ich Blut ab,
um Ihre Parameter in Ordnung zu finden.
Trostam, sollten Sie bei uns bleiben?
Muss ich auf irgendetwas achten?
Oder sollte ich bestimmte Sachen nicht testen?
Oder sollte ich etwas aufpassen,
das ich testen kann?
Ich werde Sie mit Venösen-Nahtung geben.
Deswegen sollen Sie sich nicht in den Mund oder Schlucken essen.
Wie viele Patienten sind in einem Zimmer?
Wir haben eine bestimmte Möglichkeit.
Manche sind ein Zimmer, manche sind zwei oder dreie Personen.
Was meinen Sie, in welchem Zimmer komme ich jetzt?
Wie sind Sie das schon?
Das ist das Einste in einem Zimmer.
Wenn Sie möchten,
können Sie diese Probleme oder diese Erreger bebekommen
und andere Personen anstecken.
Jetzt nehmen Sie im Waldestimmer einen Platz
und rufe ich Sie um die 2 Palästur unterhalb Wochen.
Vielen Dank.
Haben Ihre Kollegen noch Fragen?
Ja, ich frage mal in die Runde.
Ist alles gefragt worden?
Oder hätten Sie noch etwas gefragt?
Ich gucke mal in den Chat, ob das steht.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Schmerzen haben beim Durchfall.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala,
wobei es sehr leicht oder sehr stark ist?
Ungefähr zwei bis drei, also leichte Schmerzen.
Bitte beschreiben Sie die Schmerzen.
Sind Sie hier dumpf oder krampfartig?
Krampfartig, ja.
Danke.
Was hätte man noch fragen können?
Die Stuhlfrequenz hat die Kollegin gefragt.
Auch die Beschaffenheit vom Stuhl hat sie gefragt.
Was kann man noch fragen?
In Bezug auf Diarröen.
Aber nestsige Angaben zu Diarröen.
Aber habe ich die Verstande?
Sie haben keinen Fieber?
Kein Fieber.
Sie haben auch gefragt, ob ich etwas gegessen habe.
Hat er nicht so richtig beantworten können.
Was kann man fragen, ob der Durchfall durch bestimmte Sachen,
die zu sich nimmt, ausgelöst werden kann?
Zum Beispiel Milchstring.
Bei akut Diarröen ist das nicht so wichtig,
aber bei chronischer Diarröen ist das eine wichtige Frage.
Ob Bezug auf bestimmten Nahrungsmittel besteht?
Eigentlich wollte ich fragen,
ob Sie eine wichtige Ausweise haben.
Das habe ich aber so verstanden.
Es gibt Intoxikation.
Da hat er gesagt, Kartoffelsalat mit Mayonnaise.
Das kann mal sein.
Aber dann gibt es noch die Möglichkeit,
dass bei jeder neuen Nahrungsaufnahme
von bestimmten Nahrungsmitteln ausgelöst wird.
Das kann man noch fragen.
Er hat ja eher akute Diarröen.
Das ist ein wichtiges, was Sie gefragt haben.
Das ist Auslandsaufenthalt.
Was kann man noch fragen?
Sie können fragen,
können ich mal eine Medikamente?
Manchmal muss man ein bisschen nachhaken
und nachbohren beim Obst.
Manche Patienten nehmen,
werden sie Verstopfung haben, Abführmittel.
Das kann man manchmal fragen.
Gerade bei alten Leuten, die andere Medikamente haben,
ob sie Paton haben,
sollte man auch fragen, ob sie Abführmittel genommen haben.
Das kann manchmal sein.
Das ist als Folge der Abführmaßnahmen.
Aber sonst waren die Fragen alle gut.
Das ist ein wichtiges,
dass man die Fragen alle gut.
Ich gehe mal in den Chat.
Fieber war nicht Farbe und Schleim.
Er war jetzt normale Stuhlfarbe.
Schleim war dabei, hat er gesagt.
Nehmen Sie Vorsäure ein.
Warum ist die Frage Vorsäure gestellt worden?
Verstehe ich nicht.
Er hat die Frage gestellt nach Vorsäure.
Er hat die Frage gestellt.
Ich weiß nicht, warum.
Nehmen Sie MTX ein.
Nehmen Sie keine Vorsäure ein.
Aber MTX kann auch Durchfall machen.
Kann das sein?
Kann das Durchfall machen?
Ja, kann machen.
Sonst noch englische Fragen,
die von den anderen Kollegen gefragt wurden.
Wenn nicht, gehen wir zur Oberarztvorstellung.
Können wir anfangen?
Ich mache mal kurz.
Wir können anfangen.
Bitte schön.
Ich mache mal kurz.
Wir können anfangen.
Guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patient aufgenommen.
Der Patient heißt Daniel Haumann.
Er ist 80 Jahre alt.
Er ist am 1., 5., 42.
Er ist 45 kg schwer.
Er ist 1,75 m groß.
Der Patient, Herr Haumann,
stellte sich bei uns seit 3 Tagen.
Bestehenden.
Die Röhre und Müdigkeit vor.
Er hat berichtet,
dass er nicht ungewöhnliches gegeben haben.
Er hat zur Fahne,
vorhin gestohlen,
auf dem
Er hat Klagte über einen Bauchschmerzen, die Schmerzen seien krampfartig und plötzlich
aufgetreten. Sein Stuhl sei wässrig und schleimig gewesen. Der Patient gab anders eher
gestern einmal blutige Stuhl bemerkt habe. Auch der 2. berichtete der Patient, dass er vor 4 Wochen
eine Handinfektion mit Antibiosabe handelt wurde.
Handwerksinfektion, ja.
Wann war das gewesen mit der Handwerksinfektion, sagten Sie?
Vor 4 Wochen. Die Frage nach Auslöser und Auslöser ihrer Beschwerden und Völle gefühlt wurden verneint.
Keiner Beschwerden. Der Patient wohne im Pflegeheim und seine Bewohner im Pflegeheim haben keine ähnliche Beschwerden gehabt.
Die Begleiszentrum sind in Appetanz seit 3 Tagen Neuzia und Neuzia emesis. Der Patient sagte, dass er während des Drutendierer
Schwindel sei.
Er hat keine Gewichtänderung bemerkt.
Er hat wegen dieser Beschwerden keine Medikamente eingenommen.
An Vorerkrankungen sind eine Vorhoffilmung, Rheumatoide Arteritis und eine Prostarthipherapylasi.
Der Patient ist appendoktämiert.
Haben Sie alle Medikamente aufgezählt?
Ja, ich habe 6 Medikamente gezählt.
Hatten Sie das Pandopazol schon gesagt?
Ja, ich habe es geschrieben.
Warum nimmt er das ein?
Weil sie viele Medikamente nehmen, führt sie zu Gastritis.
Profilaktisch?
Der Patient ist appendoktämiert und kolesistik tomiert.
Der Patient ist vorstandig geimpft, auch Covid-19.
Der Patient ist extrauher.
Er ist seit 15 Jahren das Rauch und aufgehört.
Aber vorher habe er 5-Packung Gerach.
Trink keinen Alkohol und keine Drogen.
Der Patient ist jetzt im Rente.
Der Patient ist früher im Rente gegangen.
Er arbeitet in Büro.
Er war als Sachbearbeiter tätig und ist in den Rente gegangen.
Er ist verwitmet.
Seine Frau ist vor 10 Jahren gestorben.
Er hat keine Kinder.
Wie gesagt, der Patient wohnt im Pflegeheim.
Er ist in eigener Zimmer.
Bei der Familienanamnese ist seine Mutter an Schlaganfall gestorben.
Sein Vater an Lungenkrebs gestorben.
Der Patient habe ein Schwester und einbordet, aber keinen Kontakt mehr.
Das ist eine sehr gute Angabe.
Ich gehe von einem Verdach auf Antibiotika-Assoziale Diage aus.
Auch als differenzial diagnostisch, könnte Castro enteritis.
Also ist das eine sehr differenzial Diagnose.
Ein Infektionsgastroenteritis ist vermutlich.
Infektionsgastroenteritis könnte auch eine Nahrungsintoleranz sein.
Wenn Sie ein infektiöse Gast unterrichtet, denken Sie daran insbesondere?
Infektiöse.
Ich meine Verdachdiagnose Antibiotika-Assoziale Diage ist kloster und schwieriger.
Das ist eine besondere Form der an die Bödigassoziaten Diage.
Um meine Verdachdiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich zuerst die Patientstationäre aufnehmen.
Dann werde ich körperlich untersuchung, vor allem beim Abdommen untersuchung, durchführen.
Dann nehme ich Blut ab, ob die Entzündung Parameter in Ordnung ist oder sind.
Ich werde auch Stuhldiagnostik machen.
Ich möchte damit die Erreger bestimmen.
Ja, die bestimmen Sie Erreger?
Wie bestimmen Sie die Erreger?
Stuhlkultur.
Nach welchen Erregern gucken Sie wieder?
Da hat immer Erreger Stuhl.
Ja, kloster und diffizieler.
Parasiten.
Normalerweise bestimmt waren das Toxin von kloster und diffizieler, wie die kollegischen Schema.
Aber auch Erreger sind richtig.
Parasiten können auch mal Durchfall machen.
Welche Parasiten gibt es, die Durchfall machen können?
Ich komme darauf nicht ab.
Amöben zum Beispiel.
Oder Lampen, die ganz weit nichts sehen.
An Bakterien gibt es ein paar Bakterien, die Infektionen, die eröhnlich sind.
Wissen Sie, welche sind das?
Ich zähle die Kup.
Da viele Kup.
Die Kulde kann mal sein, aber dann gibt es noch die Salmonellen.
Ja, Salmonellen.
Wir gehen jetzt bei den Patienten von einer klosstitiven, diffizieleren,
die eröhnliche Aus- oder klosstitiven Infektionen aus.
Was machen Sie mit den Patienten?
Sie haben jetzt Diagnose gestellt.
Was machen Sie?
Nach der Bestätigung meiner Verdachtdiagnose.
Sie nehmen sie stationär auf.
Was haben Sie mit dem Patienten schon gesagt?
Ich nehme den Patienten alleine, der einzige Zimmer.
Isolation, ja.
Einzelzimmer, Isolation.
Was machen Sie dann noch mit dem?
Ich werde eine Narunkarengs anordnen.
Warum?
Weil jetzt sie gebetsch werden,
könnte der Patient nichts ertragen, wenn er essen können.
Wenn der jetzt in der Anamnese nicht angibt,
dass es durch Narungsaufnahme schlechter wird,
muss man nicht unbedingt Narunkarengs machen.
Kann man das normal essen, vielleicht?
Da ist schon ein Kost.
Kein Narunkarengs machen.
Ich würde die Flüssigkeit und Elektrolytasubstition geben.
Wenn Sie den Nachweis von Klosteridium-Toxin haben,
was machen Sie dann?
Ich werde eine Antibiotik beginnen.
Metrotrexfol.
Metronidazole.
Sehr gut.
Was sind Risikofaktoren für eine Klosteridien-Assoziaten?
Gerade bei diesen Patienten.
Welche Informationen aus einer Anäse haben Sie darauf geführt,
dass er eine Klosteridium-Infektion haben könnte?
Welche Informationen sind da wichtig gewesen?
Der Patient hat Verstände, Risikofaktoren.
Er ist höhere Alter.
Er wohne im Pflegeheim.
Er erwähnt, dass Essen im Pflegeheim schlecht ist
oder nicht gut ist.
Er nimmt viele Medikamente auch.
Welche Medikamente sind da wichtig?
Was machen Sie, dass Sie an diesen Diagnosen denken?
Die Herzmedikamente?
Diese vorherige Medikamente.
Das ist richtig, aber jetzt aktuell auch.
Welche Medikamente können das auch noch begünstigen?
Hat jemand in den Chat geschrieben?
Ich habe nicht gesehen.
Das ist ein Problem,
weil wir Patienten im Krankenhaus profilativ Pantoprozol bekommen.
Dann wird das Erlassungsbrief geschrieben.
Dann nehmen die Patienten weiter.
Wenn die Patienten eine PPE brauchen,
sollt man sie nicht geben.
Was ist noch ein Risikofaktor bei den Patienten?
Das ist ein Risikofaktor.
Das waren die wichtigsten Sachen aus der Mese.
Die Hinweise haben,
dass das in dieser Diagnose sein könnte.
Wie ist die Prognose?
Die Prognose könnte gut laufen.
Was sind die Komplikationen bei einer kloserischen Infektion?
Warum hat man das?
Der Patient kann viel dehydriert sein.
Was noch?
Was kann noch passieren?
Worst case, also schlimmstenfalls.
Wenn es eine schwere Infektion ist.
Absurdement, wenn es entroqualitisch steht.
Mit Blutung etc.
Das ist eine extreme Form einer kloserischen Infektion.
Was ist noch ein Problem bei Patienten mit chronischen Erkrankungen?
Selbst das kann man sagen.
Aber wenn sie behandelt haben,
die bekommen oft Rückfall.
Also chronische Träger.
Die haben die
nicht verwendet.
Die können, wie sie sich schon gesagt haben, andere Patienten infizieren.
Deswegen muss man isolieren.
Gibt es noch Kommentare aus dem Chat?
Das war alles komplett und gut.
Ich schau mal in den Chat rein.
Selbst das Blutung.
Das haben wir alles gesagt.
Exekurs.
Das war eine sehr gute Vorstellung.
Alles Wichtige war angesprochen.
Das waren die Kollegen.
Wo ist der Dr. Mahmut?